-I gotta say, we did "Password"
together,
and it was the most fun
I ever had.
I loved working with you
so much.
August 9th --
-August 9th.
-Tuesday nights,
in three weeks from now.
Just set your DVRs,
watch it with everyone.
It's a good --
We had so much fun.
We had great celebs come on.
-Oh, yes, Meghan Trainor --
-Meghan Trainor was good.
-She was a lot of fun.
-She was a little rusty
at first.
-Yeah, yeah, she was like --
but then she got into it,
and we're like,
"Okay, miss girl."
-Yeah, then she started
crushing it, yeah.
Martin Short made me laugh.
-Oh, my gosh, he was making me
laugh the entire time.
He's so funny.
-Ridiculous. He came out.
Jon Hamm I think
is the first episode.
-Oh, Jon Hamm, yeah,
he's so cool.
-Yeah. And he's like, yeah,
he's in the biggest movie ever.
It's like no big deal.
Speaking of being
in the biggest movie,
I want to talk about "Nope."
-Ooh!
-Yeah!
I mean, that's what
I want to talk about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm so excited!
-It's out.
-I know. I know.
-It's a big deal.
This Friday -- IMAX, everything.
You crush it when you --
when you do all the --
Did you know Jordan Peele
before you did this movie?
-So, I did a "Key and Peele"
sketch with him when I was 17.
And then I -- Yeah, we didn't --
we never did anything else
after that.
-What sketch was it?
Do I remember it?
-So, I played Malia Obama's
translator.
Remember he used to do
the translator sketches?
-Oh, the angry translator?
-Yeah, so I was angry.
I was, like, real sassy,
Malia Obama ready to get up out.
[ Laughter ]
-That's funny.
-But, yeah, that was quick
and it was funny.
He was so nice.
And that was kind of like,
the first time I had really been
like, "Okay, I'm doing comedy."
Like, I had done sitcoms before.
-Yeah.
-But I was like,
"Okay, I'm into sketch."
So I really -- I do owe it to
Jordan to get me in there
'cause now I do it all the time.
-Yeah, and, by the way,
you do so much stuff.
You're a great follow on the
socials, by the way, I will say.
-Aw, thanks.
-I saw you did something recent
with Vice President
Kamala Harris.
-Oh, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The V.P.
-Wait.
Now, do you get nervous
when you --
This was a couple weeks ago.
-I mean, it is nerve-wracking
but just because I want to make
sure, that, you know,
"Okay, I'm doing my best."
You know what I mean?
The Secret Service was there.
I was like, "How y'all doin'?"
I wanted to make sure that I was
like, "I'm professional.
Yeah, I'm not gonna hurt
the V.P."
-No, you're very professional,
yeah.
But you made her laugh by doing
an impression of her.
-Oh, my gosh. Her meme is my
favorite -- "We did it, Joe."
[ Laughter ]
"You're the President of
the United States of America."
I love it! I had to tell her,
because I'm like, "Girl!
That meme -- "We did it, Joe."
[ Laughter ]
-Speaking of vice presidents,
by the way,
a few years ago you did this
thing for --
I think it's a "Vanity Fair"
thing.
A lie detector test.
-Oh!
-And they showed you a photo of
Vice President Dick Cheney.
-[ Laughs ]
-And you did not recognize him.
And your reaction became
an instant meme.
We have a clip of this.
-Yes.
-Let's take a look.
-Who the hell is...
Ooh, y'all are really testing me
on some stuff that I --
I hate to say it. I hope I don't
sound ridiculous.
I don't know who this man is.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, he could be walking down
the street, I wouldn't --
I wouldn't know a thing.
Sorry to this man.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Sorry to this man"
was everywhere.
-Yeah, that -- I don't know what
is going on.
The Internet is so funny
interesting to me
because how would I --
I had no idea --
I really was just sorry
to the man
because I knew that I didn't
know something.
You know what I mean?
-Do people say that to you
on the street?
-All the time. That was like
I had a hit movie in theaters.
I was in "Jaws"
when that came out.
Crazy.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"Sorry to that man."
-"Sorry to this man," you know?
[ Laughter ]
Crazy.
-I mean, "Nope" is, I think,
going to be one of the biggest
movies out there.
I cannot wait for this.
I don't know anything about it.
I'm scared. Is it gonna scare
me? Am I scared?
-So there's a lot going on.
You're definitely gonna have
some spooky vibes.
But, you know, what Jordan does
with his films is, the horror
that he puts in the film is
really a metaphor
for the horrors of the world.
-Yep.
-So I think you'll really relate
to it.
A lot of things about, you know,
a spectacle,
exploitation,
our obsession with attention.
It's a lot of different stuff,
a lot of nuggets
that you're gonna keep
pulling back.
-I think this is the year of
Keke Palmer, by the way.
I'm just gonna say it right now.
-Aw.
-You are unbelievable.
-Aw, stop.
-And well deserved.
You work your butt off.
You're so good.
I wanna show everyone a clip.
Here's my favorite Keke Palmer
in "Nope."
-Ooh.
-Take a look.
-You set it up the right way.
Man, I'm talking rich and famous
for life.
How you doing? You look pretty.
Looks like she got a big house.
-How?
-"How" what? How we put it out?
-Mm.
-But that's what I'm saying.
We don't just go for
the quick cash, okay?
We go to a credible platform
to do the story.
-What's that, like "Oprah"?
-Yeah.
Like "Oprah," for example.
After that, everybody want in.
-But I'm saying, there's plenty
of videos...online.
I saw one the other day
that wasn't on "Oprah."
-I didn't say "Oprah,"
you said "Oprah."
You love "Oprah."
Look, all I'm saying is all
that...online is fake.
Low quality. Ain't nobody going
to get what we gonna get.
-What we gonna get?
-The shot.
-What shot?
The money shot. Undeniable.
Singular.
The "Oprah" shot.
-The "Oprah" shot?
-That's right!
You gotta get the "Oprah" shot!
Keke Palmer, everybody.
"Nope" is in theaters and IMAX
this Friday.
Catch "Password" August 9th
at 10:00 p.m.
on NBC after
"America's Got Talent."